uno mas are gonna be meanie - Yahoo  food and they to what they were doing  against the believers were witnesses  woman upon women whom in me no mean he  lodges in honey  and they resented them not except  because they believed in Allah The  Exalted in might the praiseworthy 1171  well aw what a cliche  Hey  need to whom belongs the Dominion of the  heavens and the earth and Allah over all  things is witness mmm love inna fatahna  meaning I want Mina Jason  tall fellow Mujahideen indeed those who  have tortured the believing men and  believing women and then have not  repented will have the punishment of  hell and they will have the punishment  of the burning fire aminos wali haughty  Langella tajiri Milton and  30 colorful one coming